post-journalism the Press lost its
Monopoly on news when the internet
democratized info to save its business
model it pivoted from journalism into
tribalism the new role of the press is
not to inform its readers but to confirm
what they already believe
post-journalism
yeah so
there was a study published in the
social science computer review
um and basically what it was a team of
researchers analyzed 27 million news
articles published between 1970 and
2019. and what they found was that use
of words like sexist and racist in the
New York Times and in The Wider liberal
media increased over 400 percent since
2012. so obviously sexism and racism
have not actually increased 400 since
2012. it's only the media's use of these
terms that's increased and this they
found this was the case anyway you know
they found that essentially what
happened was that there was some event
that had occurred that had caused a
massive shift
in the editorial policy of the New York
Times towards sex and race and I mean
this was actually a I think who was it
there was a writer who who dubbed this
the Great Awakening uh he although he
didn't he didn't refer to this specific
example but he referred to a general
Trend that that occurred with the rise
of social media in the early 2010s where
there was this sudden shift towards the
issues of sex and race and this was
driven by the media I think I think this
was driven by the fact that this the New
York Times was no longer the sole author
you know one of the sole authorities of
news anymore um with the sort of Advent
of social media and and all this
alternative media that sprang up and
stuff like The Joe Rogan podcast and all
these alternative sources of information
the New York Times had suddenly lost its
Authority um it was no longer it no
longer had a monopoly on information and
so obviously they had to do something
and I believe I don't have any hard
evidence of it but I think that this is
what led to this surge in usage of um
terms like sex is reason and the rise of
the sort of you know woke politics in
media because I feel that
it it decided that it was going to cater
to hipsters basically you know to
certain I don't want to stereotype them
too much but the kinds of people who
hang out in Starbucks and you know like
um you know drinks sort of pumpkin spice
lattes and all that you know they wanted
to sort of they thought
will be coming for you hard
yeah yeah I was trying to they're
actually quite nice I've drank drank a
few myself
I did it before everybody else
that's the most hipster thing you could
say that doesn't defend you from being a
hipster yeah okay so what you're saying
is that uh the the New York Times they
need to uh they need to re-engineer news
from being something which accurately
portrays what's going on to competing
for clicks up against people who are
significantly better at getting clicks
um what it seems like if uh racism and
sexism have increased by 400 since 2012
in New York Times in the liberal media
it seems like
racism and sexism
have been split tested as the most
limbically hijacking perfectly curated
tempting way to get people to press on a
news article
yeah absolutely yeah because the
interesting thing with these uh terms is
that they don't just get the audience uh
from the new they don't just get the
liberal audience engaged they also get
conservative audience engaged because
you know the conservative sort of uh
media ecosystem is largely reactive
which fits in with their reactionary
ideology so they they react to the
liberal politics of the day to the
liberal mainstream media and so when the
New York Times
um says that air conditioning is racist
or whatever
then Fox News is going to come out
Tucker Carlson is going to go on and
he's going to say you know look at this
madness in the New York Times you know
the world's going to hell the New York
Times now is claiming that air
conditioning is racist and the New York
Times Obviously knows that Tucker
Carlson is going to do this and that's
why they do it because they know that
they can provoke him so then Tucker gets
his audience of uh conservatives to
essentially just take part in this
dialogue to take part in this sort of
debate and that drives more traffic to
the New York Times uh when people share
it like look at this craziness you know
on social media what they're doing
they're doing the New York times's own
work for them you know they're just
sharing it even it doesn't matter if uh
people don't like the New York Times
article it's still getting shared and
that's what matters at the end of the
day people are clicking on it so that
they can hate it and I think you know
that's really the the sort of the
liberal media's business model and the
Conservative media's Business model the
liberal media will randomly accuse
things of being sexist or racist knowing
that it's going to fire a lot of people
then the right-wing media the
conservative media will sort of react
just as predicted and it will just
create it's like a sort of symbiosis
where they sort of fuel each other you
know they fuel each other's traffic and
uh you know I mean
you do see it happening either way now
as well you see you know Tucker Carlson
or whatever will make a claim which is
absolutely crazy on Fox News and then
the New York Times will write an opinion
piece about him and how he's danger to
you know everyone and he's gonna you
know create the Third Reich or whatever
like um sorry the fourth Reich but like
um you know it's uh
it's back and forth between them they
have this
this sort of tribal Warfare thing going
on and they both they both monetized it
they both profit from it and everybody
else loses because everybody else
becomes more stupid as a result
and then that's basically the media
ecosystem now I think
there's a really good quote from Dana
White and this is from three years ago
now and he says the media are not in the
news business they're in the clickbait
business they think negativity sells and
gets clicks so that's what they deliver
negativity is their product and what
he's touching on there is the fact that
people are more likely to click on
sensationalist negative stories than
they are I mean dude we see this even
when it comes to designing thumbnails
for the channel if I use a term like war
or battle uh go to war with your mind
you must battle for self-improvement
stuff like that even though they're
being used in a positive manner it's
still an inflammatory word and it gets
more clicks you know people people see
that wall that word they see the word
war and they go oh what are you gonna
click on it even if it is a a war for
more [__] hypertrophy or what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]
foreign